wo ist dein weg
achtung wir drehen die deutsche welle
produziert einen neuen online sprachkurs
für alle dieser kursniveaus weg einfach
deutsch lernen und ich denke der name
ist hier programm jeder kann mit diesen
kurs einfach deutschen das besondere ist
dass dieser kurs wirklich alles in sich
vereint er hat eine spannende geschichte
in form einer video nur wähler er hat
interaktive übungen die decken
eigentlich das abfassen lerner
normalerweise in drei lernen büchern
geboten bekommt er ist mobil verfügbar
und er ist kostenlos
also im prinzip geht es darum dass man
mit mir gemeinsam lernt in deutschland
anzukommen und die sprache zu lernen mit
alltagsproblemen und sorgen die jeder
hat und die erkenntnisse auch schön
einer produktion des gelassen wahnsinnig
viel wir sind ein kleines team bestehen
primär aus freunden und bekannten
ich glaube es ist die beste art eine
sprache zu lernen weil wir die
ablenkungen mit als stilmittel benutzen
das für seine ablenkt mit schöner film
mit guter beitragen ist bei uns das
hauptprogramm und somit lernen so
spielerisch
[Musik]
dieses projekt führen wir durch mit
unterstützung der bundesagentur für
arbeit und so ist es uns gelungen in
einem jahr mit einem sehr innovativen
produkt auf dem markt zu sein
guten tag guten abend auf wiedersehen
guten abend also bei einem normalen film
dreh ist es ja so dass die schauspieler
sich den text manchmal auch so zurecht
legen wie es ihnen gut passt und gut
über die lippen kommt und da gibt es
eben bestimmte grammatische phänomene
die in das drehbuch hinein geschrieben
worden sind
die wir behalten müssen damit wir dann
später übungen dazu machen kann
der inhalt der kommenden folge ist
obwohl so setzte mit obwohl und hier
gibt es eben zwei oder drei stellen wo
diese satzkonstruktionen vorkommt und
dachte ich ganz besonders mit den
schauspielern dass sie diese stellen
nicht ändern
dafür haben sie ihr in den anderen
stellen ein bisschen mehr freiheiten
vielleicht das selber sauer obwohl für
dich alles okay ist oder jetzt irgendwas
passiert das kann natürlich auch sein
[Musik]
[Applaus]
dieser onlinekurs ist definitiv
unterhaltsam als jedes schulbuch und
auch vielleicht als über klassische
ihnen oder onlinekurs den handel sind
gegenwärtig gematik
[Musik]